prosecutors in Texas raided the offices
of a Houston area Archdiocese looking
for so-called secret archives that could
provide evidence in a Catholic clergy
abuse case father Manuel la Rosa Lopez
is accused of molesting two teenagers
the district attorney says yesterday's
raid which lasted late into the night
was related to that case now it comes
one week after Nicky batiste reported
allegations against other priests still
serving in the Galveston Houston
archdiocese and she is here with the new
developments Nikki good morning good
morning the church uses the term secret
archives to refer to documents it keeps
confidential to protect people's privacy
any secrets among those files in Houston
are now in the hands of the district
attorney we're going to go wherever the
investigation requires us to go and
today it brought us here
investigators hauled boxes into the
offices of the Galveston Houston
archdiocese seizing evidence and the
investigation of father Manuel la Rosa
Lopez he's denied allegations of
sexually abusing two teenagers in the
late-1990s and early-2000s district
attorney brett Liggins says he's
prepared for any additional evidence
they might uncover our investigation is
focused on Father Manning anywhere it
goes after that we turn over to the
Texas Rangers and we turn over to the
appropriate federal agency CBS News
reported last week on two other priests
within the diocese facing abuse
allegations neither has been criminally
charged both still serve under the
Archbishop Cardinal Daniel DiNardo Vicki
Battista CBS News for you we tried to
speak with DiNardo who is also the
president of the US Conference of
Catholic Bishops I would prefer to do
this at another time we've been
requesting we'd love to sit down I did
another time yeah he claims the
allegations against both priests are not
credible but John Labonte says one of
them molested him when he was 16 years
old do you remember how you felt in that
moment I shrank I was like I'm not here
I left my body
Labonte told us by Skype that he was
happy when he learned police prosecutors
and Texas Rangers were searching the
archdiocese offices it cannot be easy
for the district attorney of Montgomery
County to be doing what they're doing
and I'm very thankful for the support
that they are giving the survivors the
DA tells us he's simply forcing the
church to make good on a promise of
transparency although the Catholic
Church has become kind of a sanctuary
for pedophile priests the state of Texas
is a sanctuary for victims of child
sexual assault the Archdiocese of
Galveston Houston says it's fully
cooperating with the investigation
the Justice Department has asked all
catholic diocese to preserve documents
related to sex abuse just keeps growing
it does just keeps growing
thank you Nikki